والتفاصيل بخصوص ما يجري هناك لم تعرف
كامله من دير البلح ينضم الينا الان
مراسلنا اشرف ابو عمره اشرف لا ادري ان
كنت قد علمت بما يجري في جنوب مدينه غزه
وما يحدث في هذا الموقع المستهدف والذي
ينبعث منه هذا الدخان الاسود
الكثيف الجنوب من مدينه غز وبالتحديد في
محيط حي الزيتون حيث السنه الدخان واللهب
ما زالت تتصاعد من هذا من هذه المنطقه قبل
قليل علمنا بان هناك غارات جويه اسرائيليه
قد نفذت في هذه المنطقه وسمع دوي انفجارات
كبيره حتى من موقع تواجدنا هنا سمعنا هذه
الانفجارات بشكل واضح جدا وايضا اصوات
انفجارات اخرى الى شمال من المحافظه
الوسطى سمعت في منطقه جحر الديك المحاذيه
لحي الزيتون في هذا محور تحدث اشتباكات
ايضا ويسمع دوي اطلاق نار كثيف حسب شهود
عيان تواصلنا معهم في هذه المنطقه اما في
منطقه حي الزيتون هي طائرات حربيه
اسرائيليه على ما يبدو نفذت سلسله غارات
عنيفه في هذا المحور والسنه الدخان ما
زالت تتصاعد حتى هذه اللحظه في هذه
المنطقه ا اذا هذا بخصوص ما يجري في محيط
حي الزيتون كما ذكرت اشرف والصور ما زلنا
نتابعها مباشره كما تلتقط من غلاف غزه اذا
هي غارات كثيفه على هذا الموقع وصوت
الانفجارات سمعتموها
كذلك هل هو مستمر هذه العمليه هل هي
مستمره حتى
الان نعم هي الانفجارات حتى قبل خروجنا
على الهواء كانت واضحه وجليه في في
المناطق الشماليه من المحافظه الوسطى حي
الزيتون المتاخم لمنطقه مسرح عمليات
للقوات الاسرائيليه وبالتحديد للاليات
الاسرائيليه المتواجده على شارع صلاح
الدين وتفصل محافظات وسط قطاع غزه عن
مدينه غزه هي تتمركز بالقرب من مفترق نيت
سريم سابقا هذه المنطقه شهدت صباح هذا
اليوم عمليات واصوات اطلاق نار كثيفه ايضا
سمعت في في في المنطقه المحاذيه لمنطقه
المسلخ وايضا شارع عش هناك حدثت اشتباكات
عنيفه وقويه جدا ولكن الغارات الاسرائيليه
التي حدثت قبل قليل هي نفذتها الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه لذلك السنه اللهب ما
زالت حتى الان متصاعده من تلك المنطقه
ولكن لم يحدد بعد حتى هذه اللحظات حتى حسب
الاتصالات مع شهود العيان ومع مواطنين في
مدينه غزه ماهيه هذه الغارات اين تستهدف
هذه الغارات اذا ما كانت تستهدف مربعات
سكنيه بداخلها مواطنين او حتى مناطق يعني
خاليه ولكن من السنه اللهب على ما يبدو
نجا مناوا شكرا جزيلا لك اشرف ابو عمره
كنت معنا من دير
البلح